we spoke earlier in the show briefly
about social care one of the major
issues that the government's
grappling with we're approaching boris
johnson's two-year anniversary as i said
a moment ago
which means it's almost two also two
years since he placed to fix the problem
once and for all
but unless we've all missed the memo no
plan has actually emerged so
others have stepped in to fill the void
and one of those is damien green the
former deputy prime minister
who's backing a new plan announced today
mr green
joins us now um
damian green just before we get on to
your plan on social care
can i just ask you ashford which is your
constituency is uh
the main station on the way to france if
you're going by train
are you convinced that the quarantine
requirement uh
about france uh even for people who are
double jab
is absolutely necessary um
i i can see the reasons for it and and
and sadly
uh we're not the main stop at the moment
because eurostar traffic
is down so much that they're they're
only running services
uh from london at the moment so it has
no direct effect
on my constituency what will have an
effect is uh getting
travel back uh as normally as fast as
possible so they can
reopen their full services but it's part
of a general point isn't it
that actually the balance between uh
what the local government secretary
described as caution or being
precautionary
and getting the economy going
again has the government got this
right do you think um i i i mean i
i think the the the french decision uh
is is reasonable um i think uh
you know sometimes when you have to take
decisions quickly shortly before they
come into effect um
that causes uh problems for people um
but i think the this this sort of old
debate about the balance between the
economy
and infections is a slightly false one
in that what we all want or particularly
what business wants is some kind of
certainty that
when you take an unlocking step uh that
that
uh you're not going to reverse that
later on and what we've learned
throughout this pandemic
is that a degree of caution for a time
is worth it
because that makes it easier uh
and more sensible to unlock permanently
uh for the future um but you know we're
as
everyone says we're not out of the woods
yet there is the infections are rising
as
they're expected to do um i i think it
is a good idea to continue with with
uh with monday's unlocking because as
chris whittie said if not now when this
is
this is the best time of year uh to do
that um but yeah nobody should think
we're on
um as a one-way path to to unlocking if
if we don't all continue to behave
responsibly
okay let's talk about your proposals in
relation to
social care what is different from what
you want to do
uh in what you want to do from what uh
sir andrew dilnut proposed
that set a cap for example on what we'd
each have to spend at about fifty
thousand pounds
the the big difference in in this report
uh from public policy projects
is that instead of having a flat cap of
of say 50 000 pounds
uh we suggest that it should be a
percentage of your assets now
for most people's assets that's that's
broadly speaking their house
and the reason why having a flat number
is is difficult to implement it's why
the delma proposals
have been implemented is that it has
widely different
effects in different parts of the
country in parts of the country
where house prices are much lower than
50 000 pounds will take a significant
chunk out of your estate in other parts
of the country
it won't so it's geographically unfair
if you just have a flat number
if you have a percentage figure say that
you can wherever you are in the country
keep 70 of your assets we think that's
fairer
and therefore more politically palatable
for a decision
which is going to be difficult whatever
means you try and raise the money it's
difficult
because people are going to have to pay
more than we have done in the past
because the social care system is
underfunded to the tune of
something between 7 and 10 billion a
year so
first point to be clear you are now
essentially accepting that in order to
fund social care
people are going to have to sell their
homes no i'm not absolutely not that
that's the whole point because if you
can uh keep a measurable
percentage of your assets and you won't
have to sell your home you can
buy an insurance policy or something
like that maybe using
uh features like equity release so that
you can actually use
use the value of your home but not have
to sell it and
i think the difference between the ppp
proposal and the dildo proposal
is that everyone will know that one of
the examples we use in the report is 70
percent
that 70 percent of their inheritance if
you like is
is guaranteed for their children or
their family uh
whereas under dilma the percentage that
you might be able to pass on
is wildly different in different parts
of the country
well let's just examine this point about
fairness
and i wonder if you could exp explain it
for us because
the average london householder under
your proposals would still have
whether they take out insurance or they
borrow whatever it is
they'd still have 337 000 pounds in the
kitty
after hitting your your proposed cap
compared to someone in the northeast
who'd have just 92 000 pounds and
someone in your own constituency ashford
would be left with 140 000. how is that
fairer yeah well i did the calculations
on the basis of ashford versus
hartlepool and
in in my constituency the average house
price is 370 000
in hartley pool it's a hundred and
thirty thousand if you have
a fifty sixty seventy thousand pound cap
all the sort of figures that have been
mentioned uh then in hartlepool you're
losing
more than half your inheritance um in
ashford you're losing a much smaller
proportion
and you're still left with a lot more
actual
money well but because you know from the
the way the housing system works uh
and there's a whole other argument to be
had about planning
um but the way the housing system works
it just means you are when you're alive
you have a lot more wealth and a lot
more asset just because
the same house in different parts of the
country is worth different things now
to solve that requires a lot of change
about planning and indeed leveling up so
that
uh house prices go up in other parts of
the country because they become
uh in places where people want to move
to uh but that's that's a longer term
thing
in the meantime what what you can do now
is to say wherever you are in the
country
you get to keep the same percentage of
your assets
so that you will know you know roughly
what your house is worth and therefore
if you're thinking about you know what
can i leave uh to my children
then you will know that you've got the
the bulk of that
uh to leave um you've been in number 10
for quite some time as deputy prime
minister you were
a minister in other departments has the
prime minister made the right judgment
today uh
to work from number 10 under this pilot
scheme to which
it appears every cabinet minister has
access
and hardly anybody else does well it's
not
clear who's got access to it but yeah i
mean i think the
in practical terms allowing the prime
minister and the chancellor of exchequer
to work as normally as possible
is actually quite sensible and and i
hope one of the effects of this
is to accelerate the
the pilot scheme and indeed the analysis
of the pilot scheme because this might
be
a way out of the current problems of
people not being able to
uh go to work i think the sooner we get
to that uh the better and and clearly
daily testing is one way to achieve that
so i
you know i'd be very keen if we could
move to a system where
uh if you if you have been in contact
with someone um but you're showing no
symptoms
and as far as you know you haven't got
it then
regular testing should replace isolation
i think that would that would be a
significant unlocking step
uh and it would be very welcome damon
green
thank you very much indeed